The word
dunce derives from the name of an extremely
accomplished religious scholar- John Duns
Scotus (1265/66-1308), an influential philosopher
and theologian of the High Middle Ages.
If you guessed that his ideas and those who
touted them were (somewhat unfairly) eventually
widely panned as moronic, you’d be correct.
Born near the Scottish village of Duns, from
which he took the name, Duns Scotus was ordained
into the Catholic Franciscan Order at St.
Andrew’s Priory, Northampton, England in
1291.
Over the next 17 years, Duns Scotus strongly
influenced both religious and secular thought.
One of Duns Scotus’ most notable contributions
was the idea that existence was abstract,
but it remained the same for all beings and
things, only differing in terms of degree.
However, he was perhaps most well known for
making complex arguments, and in particular
to prove the existence of God and the Immaculate
Conception.
For instance, his long and detailed argument
for the existence of God can more or less
be summed up as follows:
1) Something, A, is produced.
2) It is produced either by itself, nothing,
or another.
3) Not by nothing, for nothing causes nothing.
4) Not by itself, for an effect never causes
itself.
5) Therefore, by another; call it B.
6) We return to 2).
B is produced either by itself, nothing, or
another.
The ascending series will either continue
infinitely or we finally reach something which
has nothing prior to it.
7) An infinite ascending series is impossible.
8) Therefore, a simple first efficient cause
exists.
Given his detailed and genuinely well respected
analyses in his time, Duns Scotus earned the
nickname “the Subtle Doctor,” and an entire
school of philosophy, Scotism, was named for
him.
Important to the discussion at hand, Duns
Scotus was a fiercely devout Catholic who
even advocated for the forcible baptism into
the One True Church of Jewish children and
adults.
Along with his extremely intellectual form
of reasoning, this strict adherence to Church
doctrine and teachings are ultimately what
led to him becoming the namesake for dunce,
despite the man himself being anything but.
Skip forward approximately 200 years after
his death, and in the interim his ideas were
still being widely taught and his work still
well respected… that is, until the Protestant
Reformation had reached England.
Even before Henry VIII began the switch from
Catholicism to Anglicism, the Reformation
was tearing through northern Europe and its
ideas, as well as the new thinking that came
with the Renaissance, had begun to seep into
the island nation.
Nonetheless, traditional Catholics fought
back hard, and often relied on Duns Scotus’
theories and way of reasoning in their defense
of the Church and its doctrines.
However, many of the modern scholars of the
late Renaissance saw Duns Scotus’ arguments
as “hair splitting” and characterized
his philosophy with the pejorative “sophistry.”
Pro-Protestant forces, seizing on this interpretation
of Duns’ philosophy began to characterize
their opponents who followed him as dupes
too stupid to see behind Duns’ specious,
deceptive arguments and slavish devotion to
Catholic doctrine; and, naming them for their
hero, they became known as Duns, such as in
Tyndale’s Parable Wicked Mammon (1527):
“A Duns man would make xx. distinctions.”[1]
Over the years, Duns changed to duns and began
to be applied to those beyond the spell of
Duns Scotus, with one of two meanings.
The first- one whose study of books has left
him dull or stupid- was first seen in J. Lyly’s
Euphues, (1578): “If one bee harde in conceiuing,
they pronounce him a dowlte, if giuen to study,
they proclayme him a duns.”[2]
The second meaning- a dull-witted, stupid
person with no capacity for learning- was
first seen in F. Thynne’s Ann.
Scotl.
(1587): “But now in our age it is growne
to be a common prouerbe in derision, to call
such a person as is senselesse or without
learning a duns, which is as much as a foole.”
The present spelling of Dunce was seen as
early as 1535, when R. Layton, in a letter,
used the word to describe Duns Scotus’s
works; it was first applied more generally
to denote a stupid person in 1611, in R. Cotgrave’s
Dictionary of French & English Tongues: “Lourdaut,
a sot, dunce, dullard.
Viedaze, . . . an old dunce, doult, blockhead.”[3]
Not all has been lost concerning Duns’ reputation,
however, and he is today generally considered
one of the more important philosophers of
the Middle Ages.
Pope John Paul II even beatified Duns in 1993.
johndunsscotusAs for who came up with the
idea of putting a silly pointed hat on the
heads of a person labeled as a dunce, this
isn’t clear.
It has been suggested that Duns held that
the wearing of conical hats aided in learning,
with the shape being a symbol of learning,
funneling the knowledge into the head of the
wearer.
(This is not unlike Abracadabra cones that
have been used in healing since at least the
2nd century.)
Hence this idea supposedly championed by Duns
ultimately saw those mocking the dunces forcing
them to wear such a hat.
However, there appears to be no direct evidence
to support such a notion and the first known
reference to a dunce cap didn’t come about
until the 1840 work by Charles Dickens, The
Old Curiosity Shop, in which it states
Displayed on hooks upon the wall in all their
terrors, were the cane and ruler; and near
them, on a small shelf of its own, the dunce’s
cap, made of old newspapers and decorated
with glaring wafers of the largest size.
The word “dunce” at this point had long
been applied as a derogatory term for people
labeled as stupid or having done or said something
moronic, with no connection to Duns or his
work at all.
Given the context it was first mentioned,
and later continued to be used for (punishment
for students), the idea behind it may well
have had nothing to do with hats from Duns’
time, whether he actually wore them or not-
simply a way to visually let everyone know
said individual had done something stupid
or acted out via making them wear a silly
hat that was easy and cheap to make- just
a simple means of humiliation.
In fact, long before the idea of a dunce cap
seems to have popped up, there was the “dunce
table”, referenced in the 1624 play by John
Ford, The Sun’s Darling, in which poor performing
students were forced
to sit.